Okay, lass, lass hören.
Eins, zwei, eins, zwei, drei, boah!
Jetzt wird's lustig, mehr auch nicht, wenn Florentin mit Stefan spricht.
Aufgepasst, jetzt geht es los, fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins, hier kommt das Podcast-Snow-Fu.
Jetzt kommt das Podcast-Snow-Fu.
Podcast-Snow-Fu.
Ja, ja, das Podcast-Snow-Fu.
Da redet Stefan diese mit Florenti Will. Ja, schönes Sintero, sehr, sehr schön, gut gelungen und viel Wahres dabei, denn hier ist tatsächlich das Podcast-UFO mit Stefan Tietze, dem Mann, der hydriert ist, der sich das Wasser die Kehle herunterlaufen lässt, der da nichts kennt. Nein, nein, der wird getrunken, aber nicht fresh. Und das wird geschluckt, manchmal wird es geschluckt, manchmal rennt es einfach so die Kehle herab. Manchmal wird es gegurgelt. Gurgelt, die Schwerkraft übernimmt er den Grossteil der Arbeit. Und manchmal läuft's in die falsche Röhre, damit Guse. Flote Will ist auch dabei, Flote Will. Dankeschön, ich kann auch trinken. Nicht so gut wie Stefan, aber ich ab und zu schlürfe ich auch mal was rein, lasse ich's mir gut gehen, eis, eiskalt mag ich's am allerliebsten, schön ins Eisfach, schön vergessen, schön detoniert. Genau. Und das waren Jasper und Malte. Ganz fantastisch. Ganz tolles Intro. Wir sprechen manchmal übereinander, meist übereinander. Ja, einer mehr als der andere. Ja, wir haben jetzt Zahlen bekommen. Wir haben Zahlen bekommen, die erschüttern und erschrecken, aber auch nicht unbedingt. Überraschen. Aber trotzdem wehtun. Ich unterbreche dich häufiger als du mich. Ja, wir können euch so viel verraten, es gibt ein Forschungsprojekt im weitesten Sinne, und da kamen jetzt die harten Fakten. Hätte ich das gedacht, aus meiner Warte, ja. Hätte ich das, wenn ich von außen ab und zu mal in Folgen reinhöre, weil man die schneidet oder irgendwie Clips raussucht, nicht mehr gemacht hast, richtig, würde ich sagen, kommt es mir so voll, als würde ich dich häufiger unterbrechen, was mir leid tut. Generell tut uns ja beiden leid. Aber was wäre es für ein Podcast, wenn wir nicht die ganze Zeit das Bedürfnis hätten, etwas dazu zu tun, weil dann können wir es auch lassen. Richtig, und ehrlich gesagt bin ich manchmal vorunterbrochen zu werden, weil um ganz ehrlich zu sein, die meisten Sätze, die ich beginne, weiß nicht, wie die enden. Ich weiß nicht, wo die enden. Ich hole Luft und dann ist irgendwie Automatismus und man denkt sich, holy fucking shit, gleich passiert was ganz Schlimmes und man sieht auch so eine Pointe kommen, wo man denkt, kann man die machen, kann man die wirklich machen? Und dann komme ich ran. Aber die Frage Gegenthese, ist es nicht auch manchmal unhöflich, den anderen nicht zu unterbrechen, sondern den versauern zu lassen mit seiner kruden These, seinem grammatikalisch abenteuerlichen Satz, den er irgendwo angefangen hat, da hängt noch ein Grund irgendwo in der Luft und man merkt, ja beende den Satz gerne mal. Ja, und du machst nur diese beiden Extreme. Also du bist du bist auf beiden Extremes Arschloch, weil entweder du unterbrichst oder du guckst mich so provokativ an und denkst dir, okay, was passiert hier? Das macht er jetzt. Weil ich sag das. Ja, genau. Weil ich sag das. Da will ich auch. Ich finde es aber auch wirklich manchmal unhöflich, Leute nicht zu unterbrechen, weil manche Sätze, die sind natürlich schwer und vor allem, man hat ja nicht oft einen Punkt, man hat ja oft einen Eindruck und dann so.
Es ist ja schon, dass die Medien in gewisser Weise uns ja auch beeinflussen, weil letztlich hast du ja für die, also das, was wir denken, also wir denken ja auch nicht, bitte, bitte, bitte unterbring mich jemand. Und dann gibt es diese Geste, wo man sich nach vorne lehnt und dann so aber zurück und dann okay, bitte, bitte. Und ich einfach nur Händeringen guckecke alle an, bitte irgendjemand. Und dann hört man auch so, fade it out, denkt sich, jetzt komm rein, eigentlich so. Man muss auch die Triggerpunkte erkennen, wo man rein unterbrechen soll. Ich sage ganz ehrlich auch zu deiner Verteidigung, viele meiner Sätze sind auch gar nicht gedacht dafür, semantisch zu Ende gebracht werden zu sollen zu haben. Weil wir schreiben ja hier kein Buch, sondern es ist ja ein performativer Redepodcast. Ganz wichtig, das immer wieder zu betonen. Es gibt den Podcast nicht als Buch. Viele Fragen. Viele Fragen. Jeder Hubendubel-Mitarbeiter wird das kennen, die Leute, die scharenweise kommen. Wo ist denn Folge drei? Ist jetzt Folge drei noch erschienen? Nein, das gibt es nicht als Buch. Nein. Es gibt als Heft, als Prospekt und als Vinyl und das ist alles. Ja, es gibt eine Folge als Vinyl und wir verraten nicht welche. Ja, und eine Folge auch als Joghurt. Das waren, da haben wir kurz uns in der Molkereiecke versucht. Huiuiuiuiuiui, ist das schiefgegangen. Und was Vinyl ist denn stinkt, Molke. Was ihr denkt, was Kirschgeschmack ist, hat mit Kirschen gar nichts. Nichts, ganz zu tun zu tun. Man denkt, Moment mal, das sind doch Kirschbrocken im Joghurt. Das ist keine Kirsche. Eisabend, ich denke, Eisabend. Ihr wollt nicht wissen, was es ist, aber mit Kirsch hat das nichts zu tun, gar nichts. Nee, weil meistens hat man dann einen Eindruck oder eine Idee, fängt die an zu sagen. Das meine ich ganz ehrlich, manchmal muss man das nicht zu Ende sagen, um die Pointe zu setzen, um den Witz zu bringen. Wir haben ja auch mal analysiert in unserer Humoranalyse, dass zum Beispiel das Englische eine Sprache ist,
das sich gut für Kombi eignet, weil die Pointe am Ende ist. Das Wichtigste des Satzes kommt am Ende. Das heißt, im Englischen musst du bis zum Ende des Satzes zuhören, um das Verb zu kriegen oder so, da du weißt, worum es geht. Beim Deutschen ist es frontloaded, so du kriegst schon das meiste und dann plätschert das noch so aus. Eigentlich eignet sich Deutsch sehr, um unterbrochen zu werden. Ja, genau. Vielleicht macht es das sogar lustiger. Also, das stimmt, oft haben wir die, ist die Pointe früher gesetzt, weil das Verb sich eher committet. Also, du hast ja auch dann oft so deutsche Satzkonstruktionen mit verschiedenen Fällen und verschiedenem Genus, heisst, viele Wörter verraten schon die Richtung des Satzes. Ja. Im Englischen ja nicht, du hast weder weiblich-männlich, noch hast du grossartig Fälle, die verraten, was gerade passiert. Und am Ende hast du das Verb. Und im Deutschen ist es wirklich ein Mathematik-Sudoku, wo man am Ende eigentlich weiss, was die Antwort ist. Und da hast du mich dann aber schon unterbrochen, nach der wichtigen, nach dem, nach dem Lacher. Ja. Und es ist vielleicht lustiger. Da kannst du direkt raus. Mehr brauchst du nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen ... ja, danke, ja, genau. Also für uns ist es natürlich … ja, wir haben noch keine Infos zum Papst, können wir jetzt mal direkt sagen. Da hat es ja noch nichts ergeben, Rauch, der schweigt, und da können wir leider noch nicht sagen, in welche Richtung es geht. Aber herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Jetzt wünschte ich, ich hätte dich
unterbrochen, weil wir haben...
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, stimmt. Ich habe
ehrlich gesagt die Zeitung nicht gelesen heute, in den letzten Tagen
auch nicht. Ich bin ein bisschen durch den Wind, ich habe
wenig geschlafen, ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin.
Doch, ich glaube,
viele Grüße gehen nach Rom.
Quietscht er in Studios mittlerweile
auch eigentlich, als wir in der letzten Folge darüber
gesprochen haben, wie Lena quietscht,
Stefan quietscht jetzt auch?
Es ist ein völlig okay. Das ist so wie Meeresrauschen, das hält er mir gar nicht mehr auf. Manche Stühle müssen nicht quietschen. Ich habe letztens einen Stuhl, dachte mir, der ist ein bisschen instabil und habe geguckt und wirklich diese eine Schraube, die die Beine noch am Stuhlboden festhält, hing gerade so mit letzter Kraft, wirklich, da hätte nur noch so eine 30-Grad-Rotation gefehlt, dann fällt sie raus, dachte mir, da bin ich jetzt an einem riesigen Desaster gerade von der Schippe gesprungen, denn du willst nicht auf dem Stuhl stehen, der zusammenbricht. Ja. Ja, auf dem Stuhl stehen ist generell … Generell … Man ist verwundbar. Ja, ist so lustig, wenn man Hunde hat oder einen, reicht auch, die spiegeln dir sehr klar die Unüblichkeit, wenn man auf Stühlen steht. Ja. Es ist sehr lustig, weil sie sind sehr … Also die ganze Aufmerksamkeit liegt auf dir Und oft auch so ein skeptisches Knurren oder Bellen oder so und alles sagt, was zum Teufel machst du da. Genau. Das ist unüblich, das ist weird, das ist weird, freak, freak, freak, siehst du dich selbst gerade, muss ich dich kurz reflektieren? Muss ich dich erinnern, dass du da falsch bist? Du hast auch mal erzählt, dass im weissen Sinne ein Hund in deinem Leben oft immer bellt, wenn jemand auf dem Dach steht. Genau, Menschen auf dem Dach ist ein Riesenproblem, weil da gehören die nicht hin. Da gehören die nicht hin, da sind die falsch. Was ist das? Das ist eine Gotteslästerung. Ja, ich glaube, eh Hunde haben kein Hühnenverständnis, weil Hund ist Flachwesen. So ein Hund kann nicht klettern, eine Katze kann klettern, eine Affe kann klettern, die checkt, ah, Höhe. Ein Hund ist immer, also wenn du einen Graphen ziehst, von der Höhe eines Hundes ist es eine absolut gerade Liege. Wer kann wie hoch springen, scheisse. Wohergegen eine Katze springt manchmal auf die Couch, springt manchmal auf den Baum, so da hast du eine schöne Bewegung. Der Hund einfach direkt gerade, der Hund ist einfach so eine Linie, eine, ein, ein, ein Vektor. Flachwesen. Wie gefällt das? Ein Flachwesen. Ein Flachwesen. Ein Flachwesen. Ein gutes Wort. Das vor sich hin flacht einfach. So heisst doch die Folge, Flachwesen. Ja, ich mein Fische, was die für ne Hubsch, Hubsch, Alter, what the fuck, wie hoch bin ich? Naja, also mein Aquarium war 30 cm hoch und da eben nicht drängte sich. Ich mein, ist ein Fisch, der hoch ist, denkt er sich irgendwann wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo unten. Ist wichtig, nein, das verstehst du jetzt nicht, es ist wichtig, dass da auch Wasser ist. Ja, ja, sonst denkt er, was passiert hier? Ja, weiss ein Fisch, wie hoch er ist, weil er sieht ja, wie er sichert. Hat man mal Fisch in den Weltraum genommen, er hat Katy Perry, Katy Perry vorm Fisch im Weltraum? Katy Perry ist in der Fress-Hierarchie, steht Katy Perry über Fisch. Katy Perry vor GTA VI im Weltall, vor Fisch im Weltall. Das ist die Reihenfolge. Das ist die Chronologie, auf die wir uns geeinigt haben. Weil ein Fisch in so einer Schwerelosigkeit-Bubble, ich glaube, denen geht es da nicht gut, anders als wir Menschen. Ich finde es schon krass, dass wir Menschen überleben im Weltall. Also, Blut pumpt durch den Körper, das Herz sorgt dafür … Also, es ist schon seltsam, finde ich, dass es funktioniert. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es bei manchen … Gibt es Tiere, wo es nicht funktioniert, weil so ein Fisch hat ja diese Blase, die dafür sorgt, die sich aufpumpen kann mit Sauerstoff, und dann … so regulieren die ja die Höhe im Wasser. Und deswegen weiss ich nicht, ob die zum Beispiel dann im Weltraum Probleme bekommen, weil das nicht geht oder so. Ich glaube, wer richtig Stress hat, ist die Fledermaus. Weil die hängt ja kopfüber, wenn sie schläft. Die in der Schwerelosigkeit kommt nicht zur Ruhe, gar nicht. Weil du kannst ja nicht hängen. Also was macht die dann? Die weiss ja nicht, wo sie ... Die weiss ja nicht, wo sie ... Die weiss ja komplett nicht, wo oben und unten ist. Absolute Katastrophe. Das kannst du komplett vergessen. Was ich gehört habe von Astronauten, ist, dass ein riesiges, riesiges Problem ist. Du fließt ja in Weltall und denkst dir, oh shit, Wurmloch, Sonnenstürme, Sonnenstrahlung, Laser, Relativitätstheorie, komme ich runter und alle meine Freunde sind tot, Lord Vader, ist natürlich alles ein Riesenproblem. Grösstes Problem Hornhaut, weil du läufst ja nicht mehr auf den Füssen. Das heisst, die Hornhaut sagt, wenn er mich nicht braucht. Hornhaut, Jesus, Dramarquia, Hornhaut. Und anscheinend ist Hornhaut so fragil, hat so ein fragiles Ego, dass wenn es zwei, drei Tage nicht gebraucht wird, sind alle Zelte abgerissen, sofort weg, komplett eine Wüste hinterlassen. Das heisst, wenn du nach Hause kommst nach einem Weltraumaufenthalt, läufst du so, als würdest du so auf deinem Fleisch laufen. Weil das erste Mal in deinem gesamten Leben hast du keine Hornhaut zwischen deinem Fuss und Boden.
So, weil du läufst wie so auf so rohem, pinken Hühnchenbrustfleisch. Als würdest du auf deinem Zahnfleisch laufen. Wie so ein Hühnchen in so einer heißen Pfanne. Das heißt, diese Astronauten, diese Helden der Lüfte kommen zurück und dann... Helden der Lüfte? Ja, na klar. Oder ist ja keine Luft?
Naja, natürlich.
Sie fliegen dann mal durch Luft. Sie fliegen kurz durch Luft, ja.
So viel durch Luft wie kein anderer.
Helden des, was hast du sonst?
Helden des luftleeren Raums.
Space, Space, Space, Space, Heroes in Space.
So, ist Allheld.
Kommen zurück, Star Spangled Spanner spielt, alle sind da und alle hier kommen sie und die so, so auf den Zehenspitzen, weil sie keine Hornhaut mehr haben, es ist richtig demütig. Jetzt war ja der Blue Origin Fluch, Fluch. Ja, okay, ein neuer Fluch, ich habe nicht, ich habe mir durchsteigen lassen, wie ich die ganze Aktion fand, da habe ich jetzt schon wieder durchsteigen lassen. Okay, dann gehen wir da doch mal rein habe nicht … Ein neuer Fluch. Ich habe wieder durchstellen lassen, wie ich die ganze Aktion fand.
Da habe ich jetzt schon wieder durchstellen lassen.
Sehr schön, okay, dann gehen wir da doch mal rein. Arbeiten wir uns doch mal rein.
Warum empfandest du das als Fluch und was ist es überhaupt? Ich kenne das nicht.
Jeff Bezos hat ja auch diese Raumfahrtfirma, denn es ist ja so, dass die reichsten Männer der Welt
bauen sich Raumschifffirmen, um ins Weltall zu erobern.
Ja, Endgame ist, glaube ich, Mars zu besiedeln, I don't know.
So, und jetzt haben sie ja dann auch so Weltraumtouristenpläne und sowas. Und dann wurde eben Katy Perry unter anderem ins All geschossen, ist dann da kurz geblieben und dann wieder zurück. Meanwhile, das deutsche Unternehmen Isa Aerospace, bei dir aus der Heimat, aus Minger, hat jetzt die erste deutsche Rakete versucht, ins All zu schießen. Ich habe nämlich extra gemerkt, wann der Start ist. Gucke ich dann gerne live, schaue ich mir das an. Wir haben auch so eine Berichterstattung. Auf Twitch sind die auch immer, oder? Genau, oder bei YouTube live, kann man das gucken. Leicht zugänglich. Ist cool, ja, und dann kann man da in den Starts gucken, da haben die oft so Ingenieursmenschen, die da mitgebaut haben. Und in dem Fall war es so eine junge Deutsche und ein junger deutscher Mann, die haben das zusammen moderiert. Aber als ich habe mich gewundert, ich habe dann so kurz nach, ich habe so eine Minute verpasst, den Start reingeschaltet und es stand schon, vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit, wo ich dachte, okay, hier passiert. Und dann war ich in so einer Gruppe mit so Nerds und dann war einer geschrieben so, wow, habt ihr das gesehen? Unfassbar, es direkt explodiert. Und ich dachte mir, crazy, habe ich verpasst. Ich war genau zehn Sekunden zu spät drin, denn nach 45 Sekunden ist die Isar Aerospace gestartet, es sah gut aus und da ist glaube ich eine Vorberichterstattung und wir sind aufgeregt, wir gucken, wie es läuft, bla bla bla und dann ist die 20 Sekunden hochgeflogen, da hat man schon gemerkt, okay, irgendwas passiert, weil die so die Richtung verändert hat, das kann nicht gut sein und dann dann ist sie einfach einmal umgedreht, U-Turn gemacht und dann wirklich auf dem, das sah auch geil aus. Das war ein Navi-Problem vielleicht aber auch, ne? Einfach ein Navi-Problem. Nee, die haben unsere Idee, beziehungsweise die von Harmontown im Podcast, wo man gesagt hat, warum fliegt man nicht mehr nach unten? Genau. Man will nicht mehr nach oben, warum nicht mehr nach unten? Richtig. Ich meine, der Weltall ist ja nicht nur oben. Oben haben wir quasi alles erkundet, alle Sterne, aber unten ja auch nichts. Nichts, was unten ist.
Wir wissen nichts, was unten ist.
Und dann ist es aus Norwegen gestartet, da ist nämlich der Spaceport auch geil.
Einfach in Norwegen, so eine geile Landschaft, fliegt dann da hoch und dann direkt abgestöscht.
Und sind auch Leute umgekommen?
Nein, nein, nein, es war einfach ein Raketentest, genau.
Aber da sind gerade die Europäer, ne, sind da. Also das ist wirklich, natürlich haben sie gesagt, ja, es war auch ein bisschen abzusehen und es war aber nicht klar. Moment, da will ich einhaken, wie es war abzusehen. Du musst viel testen und viele Messungen machen, bis du eine gesicherte Rakete ins All schicken kannst. Also ich glaube schon, dass die da etwas gelernt haben, dass es nicht der Plan war, dass sie nach 20 Sekunden abfällt. Dass sie vielleicht nach oben fliegen sollen, nicht nach unten. Das wäre doch mal vielleicht eine Klektion. Kannst du ja mal in eine Mail schreiben oder so. Ich werde mal eine schnippische Mail formulieren. Info-Ad. Generell mehr Mails an Info-Ad. Ja, Info-Ad immer gut. Einfach viel Infofordern, ja, finde ich richtig gut. Ich habe jetzt auch so eine Idee gehabt, ich wollte so Neonröhren bei mir so hinhängen, so schick, unverkleidet, nicht in so Fassungen, sondern so schicke LEDs, so gibt es ja jetzt so LED-Röhren, und so habe ich einfach so dumme Fragen gehabt, einfach an Info-Ad-Herstellername geschickt, kam eine Antwort zurück, haben mir super nett geholfen, kamen so Schaltpläne zurück. Mega geil! Mega geil! Info-Ad! Das ist die Info-Ad-Idee, der Info-Ad-Weg. Ja gut, wir haben ja Zentrale, ne? Also bei uns die Zentrale, bei uns läuft das alles noch zentralistisch zusammen, ne? Also bei uns gibt es noch einen Kern, einen Knotenpunkt. Wenn ihr das mitteilen wollt, geht mal auf das podcast-ufe.com oder podcast-ufe.fail, könnt ihr unten, wenn ihr unten scrollt, eine E-Mail an die Zentrale schicken. Genau, nutzt da bitte aber gerne das Online-Formular, weil wie gesagt, also diese E-Mail-Adresse, ja genau, aber die Zentrale selber ist schwer zugänglich aktuell, weil die kriegen ja wir, wir kriegen doch die E-Mail-Nachrichten. Ja, weil die an Zentrale geht. Es geht auch an Flo-Fan. Das ist viel besser. So können wir auch auf vier Nachrichten antworten. Ich glaube, ich habe letzte Woche auf mehr Nachrichten geantwortet als davor jemals. Einfach weil es nicht an meinem alten, kruden Laptop hängt, wo noch die Zentrale drauf ist, geht lieber übers Online-Formular. Das ist auch nur eine Mail. Online-Formular sind auch einfach nur Mails. Das ist auch die grösste Lüge, ne? Also macht euch da nichts vor. Was glaubst du ein Online-Formular, was es ist? Glaubst du, du bist was besseres Online-Formular? Du bist wie ich eine fucking Mail. Dann geht man auf seine Website und denkt sich die Mail, ich schreib doch nicht an die Mail, ich nehme das Online-Formular. Und es ist exakt das gleiche, es ist einfach nur ein anderes Interface. Aber man fühlt sich schlau, man fühlt sich, als hätte man wirklich was geleistet. Ich finde es eine grosse Seuche, diese Online-Formulare eigentlich. Also wenn wir nicht selber eins hätten, würde ich jetzt auch noch mehr ausholen, aber so halte ich mich ein bisschen zurück. Ich denke mir nur, weil... Bis auf 30 Prozent Rant gerade. Was mich nämlich so richtig nervt ist, dass man, wenn man einfach eine scheiß Mail-Adresse auf der Website steht, wo man draufklicken kann, öffnet sich auf das Mail-Programm einfach direkt. Man schreibt eine Mail, hast du denn eine Mail im Postausgang? Ja. Das ist ein wichtiger archivarischer Beweis. Den kannst du haben. Du weißt auch, wem habe ich eigentlich geschrieben, wer hat nicht geantwortet. Ich habe zum Beispiel so ein Projekt, so ein Zimmermann-Schreiner-Projekt bei mir, und da habe ich so ganz vielen Leuten gefragt, ob sie Lust haben, das zu machen. Und ich finde diese Mails nicht mehr, weil das zu 80 Prozent so Online-Formular-Scheiße war. Man kriegt von deinem Privatleben immer nur so punktuelle Einblicke, ne? Also LED-Röhren und ein … ein nicht näher, der für die Schreiner-Projekt. … ein Schreiner-Projekt. Und jetzt denke ich mir natürlich, hm, er ist gerade im ESA-Hype. Vielleicht hat er wieder eine Raumfahrtphase. Röhr, baust du eine Rakete, Stefan? Ja, aus Holz. Du sagst einfach mal, habe ich direkt. Baust du eine Rakete. Eine gut beleuchtete Rakete aus Holz. Das macht die ESA nämlich falsch. Die nutzen kein Holz. Das ist nicht die ESA, es ist ein privates Unternehmen, ein deutsches Unternehmen, ESA Aerospace. So, Isar, okay. Isar, aber wie der Fluss? Wie der Fluss, was da bloß ist. Isar, okay, wie der Isar Amperwerke. Weil da gibt es einen riesen, riesen Space Hub. Und nutzen die die Kraft des Flusses, Isar? Isar, die Isar wird komplett ignoriert in der ganzen Rechnung. Isar in Kraft? Ja, klar, Isar Amperwerke ist ein grosses Wasserkraftwerk. Rinnsal. Nee, nee, nee, ist ein grosses Wasserkraftwerk. Ich habe als Kind immer gelernt, Wasserkraft ist die Zukunft. Da habe ich gedacht, irgendwann hat jeder Fluss ein Wasserkraftwerk, und da ist ja unendlich Kraft und stellt sich heraus, nee, wir können das Wasser nicht aufhalten, das muss weiter. Das muss, das hat ja irgendeinen Zielort aus gutem Grund, das muss da ja hin. Naja, jetzt in Köln, da gibt es ja dann, da gab es ja dieses Riesenloch, dieses Tagebau-Loch, wo man einfach, das ist das grösste Loch Europas oder so, wo diese Riesenbagger, die das, es sind nur Rekorde werden auch bestelltellt, wo das, das grösste Fahrzeug der Welt sind diese Bagger, die da da, und das wird ja jetzt aufgefüllt mit Wasser. Das wird ja entsteht jetzt ein Riesensee. Und aber dann? Aber in, das, da leben wir nicht mehr, wenn das voll ist. Und da wollen die nämlich den Rhein stoppen. Du hast gerade gesagt, man kann den Fluss nicht stoppen. Die wollen vom Rhein was abzwacken. Ja, aber dann kommt ja irgendwo weniger Wasser an. Das denke ich mir genau auch. Und da haben wir, deswegen Info-Add. Einfach jetzt Info-Add grössteslocheuropas.org und dann gucken. Das grösste Loch Europas, das ist schon auch geil, ne? Also wie so ein grosses Loch. Ich meine, in Schottland hast du ja Loch Ness, die haben ordentlich Löcher, aber wir haben einfach das Loch Cologne. Das ist riesig, riesig. Und das wird komplett mit Wasser vollgemacht, weil dann entstehen da, glaube ich, jetzt steht einfach eine neue Stadt an dem See. Unter Wasser. Wie so der Bodensee, nochmal, nochmal. Unter Wasser, okay.
Das ist ja tatsächlich, also manchmal werde ich ja so ein bisschen sentimental und denke mir so, wo will ich eigentlich hin, also wie sieht mein Lebensabend aus, also mal so Sesshafthaus und so und Wald und wo will man eigentlich leben. Und mein Traum ist es tatsächlich, einen eigenen See anzulegen.
Also wirklich über Jahre hinweg in so einem kleinen Bagger mit Podcast auf dem Ohr,
wirklich schlussend. Und mein Traum ist es tatsächlich, einen eigenen See anzulegen. Also wirklich über Jahre hinweg in so einem kleinen Bagger mit Podcast auf dem Ohr wirklich schön zu graben und mir dann Gedanken zu machen, welche Pflanzen müssen da sein, Algen und so. Wie gross reden wir? Also ich überlege immer, wie vergrössert man einen See? Das ist immer meine Frage.
Ja, nicht tiefer, sondern breiter.
Ja, aber wie? Weil du kannst ja nicht deinen Bagger in den See setzen und dann die Küste abtragen. Also meine Idee ist immer, ich grabe neben dem See noch ein Loch und dann mache ich den Damm dazwischen quasi kaputt und dann fließt es ineinander über und dann hat man so eine Acht oder wie so ein Durchteil hier, so ein Durchlauf. Aber du willst auch eine Insel auf dem See haben. Ich will Inseln auf dem See haben, einen Baum auf der Insel. Eigentlich will ich eine See, auf dem See ist eine Insel und auf der Insel ist auch wieder ein See und da ist auch wieder eine Insel drauf. Gibt es. So, und dann ist meine Lebensfrage, wie viele Ebenen schaffe ich? Ich glaube, es gibt irgendwo im Atlantik, gibt es dieses Phänomen. Ich glaube, es gibt acht Ebenen. Acht Iterationen. Also du hast See, Insel, See, Insel, See, Insel, See, Insel. Das ist, glaube ich, das Maximum aktuell. Und mein Ziel, also sagen wir mal, wenn ich in Rente gehe, Podcastrente, so mit 60 oder so, 64, ich weiss nicht wo aktuell Podcastrentenalter, Einschicksalter steht. Früh, glaube ich. Sehr früh. Und dann, ab dann nur noch gucke ich, wie viele Ringe sehe, schaffe ich, bis ich tot bin. Das ist dann alles. Oder ist das wie Blatt Papierfalten, es geht immer nur bis sieben. Das ist nur neun, sieben oder neun? Sieben. Sieben ist die Zahl? Sieben oder neun. Was ist die Zahl? Also was ist die Zahl? Sieben. Ist es die sieben? Ich dachte immer die elf. Die Zahl? Ja, also die Zahl einfach so, wo alles zusammenkommt. Irgendwo zwischen sieben und elf, ne? Es wird nicht dreissig sein, sind wir mal ganz ehrlich. Nee, also es wird nicht dreissig sein. Es wird auch nicht zwanzig sein. Es wird auch nicht zwanzig sein. Es wird auch, lege ich mich fest, es wird auch nicht fünfzig, sind wir mal ganz ehrlich. Nee, also es wird nicht 30 sein. Es wird auch nicht 20 sein. Es wird auch nicht 20 sein.
Es wird auch, lege ich mich fest, es wird auch nicht 15 sein.
Ich glaube, die Zahl ist unter 15.
Auch 14 ist es nicht.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt werde ich langsam nervös.
Eins bis 13, da irgendwo liegt die Zahl zwischen.
Was ist denn die höchste Unglückszahl?
Also ich glaube, es gibt die vier irgendwo im asiatischen Raum als Unglückszahl, ne? Also ich glaube, es gibt die vier irgendwo im
asiatischen Raum als Unglückszahl, was super dumm ist, so eine kleine Zahl, aber jetzt gar nicht
… Ja, aber bei uns ist die dreizehn ist auch recht … Die dreizehn ist vergleichsweise hoch. Also du hast ein Hochhaus, hast du selten dreizehn Stück.
Nee, kommt schon, beim Hochhaus ja, aber … Hochhaus ja, ja … Nee, Nee, du hast recht … Na klar, beim Vier ist es halt dumm im Vergleich.
Vier ist es superdumm einfach.
Aber ich … tatsächlich habe erst jetzt langsam vor ein paar Wochen gecheckt, warum es den Wagen 13 nie gibt bei Zügen.
Ach was. Ach, und deswegen machen die so dann … so 21, 22, 23 machen die, ne?
Ja, oft hat der Bahn vierzehn Waggons, aber eigentlich dreizehn. Und du gehst von zwölf zu vierzehn? Ja. Wenn ich im Wagen vierzehn sitze oder zwölf, es gibt keinen Wagen dreizehn. Wann verabschieden wir uns als Gesellschaft von so einem Schwachsinn eigentlich mal? Wir hatten das Jahr 2013, wir hatten das Jahr, wir hatten sogar schon das Jahr 13. Also, wir hatten sogar, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, das Jahr 1313. Und wir sind gut. Und nichts ist passiert. Gut, die Pest, mein Gott. Ja, kommst du durch. Bisschen Schnupfen ist doch kein Problem. Aber das haben wir auch überlebt als Gesellschaft, als Welt. Oh, meine. Ganz, ganz schlimme Zukunftlücke. Ach, mein. Ja, aber ich bitte. Ich glaube, das Ding ist, du willst halt nicht der Typ sein, der bei der Bahn ist. So jetzt, neuer Paps wurde gewählt, neuer Bahnchef wird auch bald anstehen, sag ich jetzt einfach mal auf den Tisch. So, und dann kommt da auch mal so ein junger Gen-Z-Revoluzzer, der einfach mal sagt, so Freunde, jetzt hier mit dem ganzen Aberglauben mal raus. So reden, Gen-Z. Jetzt mal ganz der Aberglaube kommt erstmal raus, so jetzt passen wir mal auf, Digga, ja. Also, wisst ihr, was goaded ist? Die 13 ist goaded. Also, Wagen 14 ist jetzt Wagen 13. 13 ist based, okay? 13 ist based. So, und dann ist der Wagen, und dann, 13 Tage später, Riesenzugunglück, Zug fällt die Brücke runter. Und nur ein einziger Wagen ... Berechnungen zufolge, wäre das nicht passiert, wenn es den Wagen 13 nicht gegeben hätte. Und der Zug fällt leider so ungünstig, dass nur der Wagen 13 komplett zusammengestaucht wird, wodurch alle anderen Wagen unbeschadet sind, aber nur Wagen 13. So, und jetzt will ich den Typ in der PK sehen, in der Pressekonferenz. Jetzt will ich den Typen sehen, wie er da ist. Du sparst keine Zeit, wenn du die Abkürze danach erklären musst. Naja, es ist eine Zeitinvestition. Ich erkläre es jetzt einmal. Wir haben einen Zwo-Siebzehner, also einen dringenden Tatverdacht und mit Flucht. Ja, dann sag das doch vor! Gut, also er sitzt in der Presse-PK und muss sich dann rechtfertigen. Warum 13? Dann sagt er, 13 ist goaded, 13 ist based. Aber da willst du halt nicht der Typ sein, der den grossen Fehler macht. Können Sie, Entschuldigung, können Sie doch mal mit anderen Worten sagen, was 13 genau ist? Äh, 13 ist, ähm, based, 13 ist bay. Genau, können Sie das nochmal mit, also irgendwie mit anderen? 13 ist lit, 13 ist lit, ist skibbidi.
Im Sinne von gut oder im Sinne von schlecht?
13 ist sigma.
Sigma ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
13 ist gut.
So, du willst nicht der Typ sein.
Ich glaube, jede Veränderung birgt die Gefahr, dass es danach noch viel, viel, viel, viel schlimmer ist. Mal allgemein. Also lieber nicht anrühren, glaube ich. Okay, das ist das Konservativste, was du jemals gesagt hast. Ja, ja. Aber gut, ich bin für Veränderungen. Ich denke mir, mach den Wagen 13. Und wisst ihr was? Mach doch auch noch etwas dazwischenischen. Ja, mach Wagen 13 und danach einfach Wagen 666, fuck it. Ja, jetzt, dann ist doch eh schon alles egal. Ja, dann ist wirklich alles egal. Und dann einfach nochmal Wagen Lucifer, rein. Und dann einfach nochmal Wagen Jeffrey Dahmer und einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Das Schicksal auch mal rausfordern. Ja, aber ich habe wirklich gedacht, dass man da eigentlich so bei hinten aus sein sollte, man hat aber wirklich noch Züge dann, wo es die 13 nicht gibt, da dachte ich mir, komm, deutsche Bahn, also das passt nicht, das muss aufhören. Vor allem das ist, also hat das nicht auch mit Freitag der 13, mit diesem Börsencrash und so, das ist ja nicht mal irgendwie religiös fundiert, oder? Also das ist ja einfach nur so Popkulturell. Okay, warum ist so ein Wagen 11 nach 9-11?
War so schlimm.
Also, ich meine,
da muss halt der 9 oder 11 so.
Okay, also Wagen 9 ist weg,
Wagen 11 ist weg.
13 ist eh weg, klar.
13 ist eh weg.
So sieben, die sieben Todsünden.
Sieben Todsünden, sieben weg.
Sieben weg.
Sechs ist schmutzig. Vier hast du gerade auch gesagt. Vier ist auch weg, aus Respekt vor den Asiaten. Okay, also wir haben jetzt Wagen. Wir haben eins und hundertsechzehn. Irgendwie sieht jetzt der Zug so aus wie alle deutsche Bahnzüge, wo manche Wagen fehlen und so. Jetzt hast du diesen Schweizer Käse an der Bahn. Ja, aber zum Thema Sicherheit natürlich auch, wir sind natürlich aktuell
wieder im Fieber von
The Rehearsal.
Staffel zwei, wir alle
lieben Nathan Fielder natürlich, nach der
fulminanten Staffel eins, The Rehearsal.
Sehr, sehr geile Serie, etwas schwer anzuschauen,
aber ihr Füchse findet das schon raus. Ich kann das nicht.
Und da findet ihr
The Rehearsal, Staffel zwei.
Das ist generell eine Serie, da geht es darum, dass Nathan Fielder sehr viele soziale Situationen konstruiert. Also er baut grosse Sets, konstruiert, es geht sehr viel um Metaebenen, um Spielen und Darstellen und was ist man, es ist wirklich fantastisch, schwer zu erklären, aber man checkt sofort. Und jetzt in Staffel zwei geht es um Flugsicherheit, weil es ist anscheinend so, dass viele Unfälle dadurch verursacht werden, dass der Co-Pilot sich nicht traut, dem Piloten das Steuer zu entreißen. Da haben wir auch im Podcast darüber gesprochen. In Kulturen mit flachen Hierarchien gibt es weniger Unglücke. Hast du verstanden? Ja, habe ich verstanden. Ich fand das Wort Unglücke ein wenig zu allgemein gewählt. Das ist einfach. Aber okay, du bist anscheinend sehr parteiisch bei dem Thema. Also kann es sein? Es gibt weniger Unglück. Also ich hab das... Nee, ich dachte gerade beim Sprechen, es wird sich ja nicht nur auf Flugzeugunglücke. Ja, gut ist ja die Frage, ob du so zwei Leute hast.
Im Auto bist du alleine oder greift der Weifere an?
So, auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben Alain Tschernobyl gesehen, vom großartigen Craig Mason, die Serie, den wir mögen,
weil das ein Podcast-Kollege vom Podcast Script Notes, den wir schon lange hören, ist.
Richtig.
Und da geht es ja auch darum, dass vermutlich auch die Hierarchien und generell der sowjetische Führungsstil, die Art der … Sag, wann ich dich unterbrechen soll. Gerne. Zwei Mal, wenn ich dich unterbrechen soll. Ja, genau, nee, absolut. Ja, nicht mich mit was ganz anderem, kannst du mir helfen mit Wörtern, die ich suche, nicht einfach abwürgen. Dyatlov, Dyat, Diadloff. Ja, da liegt es ja schon daran, dass er sich nicht getraut ist, den fucking Chefs zu sagen, dass er alles in Bacher untergeht. Und vielleicht war das auch ursächlich für den Fall. Das heißt, vielleicht gab es einen politischen Grund für Chernobyl. Absolut. Und das ist ja auch bei den Flugzeugunglücken so. Genau, und da geht es eben darum, dass Co-Piloten trainiert werden sollen durch soziale Rollenspiele, dass sie selber das Steuer in die Hand nehmen. Auch metaphorisch genommen ist es wirklich ganz fantastisch. Toll. Es ist eine Serie, die in ganz viele unterschiedliche Richtungen schlägt. Kann ich nur empfehlen, die das Podcast-UFO. Empfehlung, Helung, Helung, Helung, Helung, Helung, Helung. Hast du mal was geheilt? Du hast kaum gehählt. Selten gehählt. Ich habe was geklaut letztens. Also ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob es Diebstahl ist, da muss unsere Juristerei mal wieder einhaken. Aber jeder kennt die Situation von loser Ware. Ja, also zum Beispiel, du bist im Supermarkt und Joghurette, du hast Lust auf Joghurette. Also schaust du in die Joghurette-Abteilung, in die Joghurette-Flügel und dann sind die Joghurette-Packungen fein säuberlich aufgereiht, du kannst sie also kaufen, als Ware. Aber jetzt durch ein Unglück, das du nicht mitbekommen hast, hat sich eine dieser Joghourettenpackungen entzweit, zerrissen, selbst karambolajuliert und die Joghurttenriegel liegen überall. Was ist hier geschehen? Unwichtig. Du arbeitest lieber an der Trümmerbillseitigung. So, jetzt sind aber ja einzelne Joghurttenstängelchen nicht für den Einzelverkauf gedacht. Korrekt, die kannst du gar nicht kaufen. Du könntest diese einzelnen Joghurt-Regelkarten kaufen. Ja, aber da kannst du auch das Regal im Supermarkt nicht kaufen. Das kannst du aber nicht einfach mitnehmen. Du kannst auch nicht, wenn da oben ein Werbeplakat hängt im Supermarkt, das ist ja nicht zum Kaufen. Das kannst du ja nicht abmachen und durch den Laden tragen. Aber bei diesen Joghurt-Stängeln, da denkt man sich, na gut, da gibt es keinen Schaden. Die können nicht wieder verkauft werden, die werden weggeschmissen oder der Teamkasse zugeführt oder Teampickning. Da kann nicht mehr einen gönnen. Das ist nicht illegal, oder? Ich meine doch. Ist ja nicht deins. Aber das ist ja nichts wert. Doch, das ist ja ...
Naja, aber du kannst doch zum Beispiel, was man bei so Aldi oder so nimmt man ja auch manchmal die Kartons mit. Die Kartons, um da seinen Einkauf reinzutun. Das finde ich auch. Die sind einfach kostenlos, die kannst du mitnehmen. Einfach eine Ansage. Die kannst du einfach mitnehmen. So ein Boss-Move. Aber ich denke mir, die freuen sich ja sogar, wenn du ihren Müll wegnimmst. Hier, sowas denke ich mir, das ist wieder was für Flohundin Serviceecke, herauszufinden, mögt ihr das dann, wenn man, wenn er so einen Sirup, so den Beersirup, wo ihm gefallen ist und ich liege da und lecke das ab, finde ich das geil? Soll ich als Kunde meinen eigenen Unrat weglecken? Und wollt ihr dabei Augenkontakt oder nicht? Das ist die Frage, die ich mir stelle. Das ist die Frage. Da würde halt jetzt helfen, wenn man eine Serviceperson hätte.. Gut, ich meine, dir ist ein Glas Ahornsirup runtergefallen, da sind halt Scherben drin und du leckst es trotzdem auf. Ist deine persönliche Gesundheit, ne? Du hast anscheinend eine recht lederige Zunge, das sehe ich von hier. Die hat schon einiges mitgemacht, die hat schon einige Oberflächen gelegt, unterschiedlichster Rauheiten. Oh ja! So, und dann denke ich mir so, das ist lose Ware, stecke ich ein. Und ich habe jetzt auch in einem Supermarkt lose Ware einen Plastikfisch gesehen. Der war in so einem Netz von verschiedenen Plastikfischen. Was ist Plastikfisch? Es ist eine Plastik-, es ist so eine Sandform. Jetzt habe ich noch mehr Fragen als vor der Erklärung. Es ist eine Sandform, nein, es ist das Wort, ne, eine Sandform, wo man im Sandkasten spielen kann. Ah, okay, wir sind quasi ein Kinderspielzeug. Da hast du einen Plastikfisch. So, und die werden normalerweise in so Netzen verkauft mit unterschiedlichen Motiven. Da hast du den Seestern, den Fisch, klassische, nautische Sachen. Ja, ich hätte auch nicht mehr gewusst. Perfekt unterbrochen, danke. Das macht dich zu einem guten Also nehme ich den Plastikfisch mit. Habe ich quasi geklaut? Oder ist es Diebstahl? Ich weiß es nicht. Wie ist das mit loser Ware? Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich war noch im Baumarkt, da haben wir auch darüber gesprochen, dass man ja manchmal, also wenn man da einen Baumarkt-Mitarbeiterin fragt, ich erkenne da von diesen Schrauben, welche brauche ich, und die dann einfach so da rein, hier, nimm sie und tschüss. Und dann ist es so, ja, es ist doch Diebstahl, ja, who fucking cares, ciao, es ist einfach Rogue, Wild West, Baumärkte sind crazy. Und da war ich doch nicht an der Information, weil, ne, wir hatten es ja gerade mit meinen weirden Heimwerkerprojekten, die ich gerade habe. Genau, was hast du gekauft? Also welche, möchte ich nicht sagen. Also aus welcher Abteilung hast du gekauft? Sagen. Aus welcher Abteilung hast du gekauft? Strom. Warum ist es geheim? Strom, Strom, Strom. Okay, Kabel, Sicherung, Verteiler, alles. Alles. Argo-Klemmen. Argo-Klemmen. Okay. So, erst mal, da wurde, ich habe tatsächlich in einem anderen Haushalt geholfen und habe eine Steckdose neu angebracht auf der anderen Seite des Raumes, wo ich vorher nicht da war.
Das übrigens habe ich geschafft und das ist ein Skill, wo ich denke, jetzt habe ich so ein neues Level freigeschaltet.
Jetzt habe ich ein Level an Freiheit, weil ich kann jetzt einfach Strom, kann ich überall hinlegen.
Aber wie kommst du in die Wand rein?
Nee, ich nehme es mir von von einer Steckdose.
Moment, du hast einfach ein Kabel durch das Zimmer gelegt, oder was? Ja, genau, in der Wand lang.
Halt natürlich Mühe gegeben und schön, dann mit dem Kabelkanal oder so. Ach so, du hast ein Kabel
verlegt. Ja, okay, verstehe. Nee, und dann halt ein, ja, genau. Ja, aber ich finde es toll, ich finde es super, ich finde es super. Ich habe mir Strom von A genommen und bringe es nach C. Ja, aber das hätte ich jetzt nicht unterschlagen, weil wenn ich an eine Steckdose denke, wir schauen mal irgendeine beliebige Steckdose an, sehe ich nicht da so ein freches Kabel da so rausquellen. Doch, aber die zum Beispiel, die wir hier gerade sehen, die kann ich dir überall hinhängen. Über wo ist das Kabel? Ich habe es da reingestochen, mir da Strom abgezwackt und dann mache ich ein Kabel dahin. Hier kommt es jetzt aus der Wand. Es gibt ja auch teilweise so Verteilerdinger oben oder so. Du machst einfach so einen Plastikdeckel auf und da hast du Kabel drin und da kann ich auch was rausnehmen und dann leg ich es dir woanders hin. Ich weiß, es ist nicht so wahnsinnig schwierig.
Da nimmst du aber schon viel die Sicherung raus.
Natürlich, es ist alles nicht so wahnsinnig wild. Ich fand es nur cool, weil ich sonst kein handwerklich geschickter Kerl bin, ist es für mich irgendwie ein neues Level, was ich freigeschaltet habe, das fand ich cool. Und für dieses Projekt, bla bla bla, brauchte ich aber Sachen im Supermarkt. Und dann war da so ein Mitarbeiter und dahinter so eine Schlange. Und davor waren ganz viele Kunden mit ihren individuellen Problemen und ihren individuellen Sachen. Und es ist nur, alle haben weirden Rando-Shit in der Hand und stehen bei ihm. Alle gleiche Körperhaltung, gleicher duller Gesichtsausdruck, alle random Gegenstände in der Hand mit den merkwürdigsten Fragen der Welt. Und ich musste wirklich lachen, weil der eine so, ja, für mein Projekt brauche ich so die Siebener, aber ich habe nur Neuner. Und man denkt sich, was machen alle zu Hause? Was haben die für Projekte? Wir wohnen doch alle in ungefähr den gleichen Grundrissen, mit den gleichen Problemen und den gleichen Baustellen. Dann will der eine mal ein Brett da, der andere will ein Brett da, so ein Regalbrett. Es gibt unfassbar viele Leute, denen einfach langweilig ist. So ein Rohreimer. Ja, ich höre das auch mal so von irgendwie, ja, meine Eltern wechseln jetzt die Fenster aus. An welchem Punkt ist dir so langweilig, dass du sagst, nee, die Fenster müssen noch … Schatz, alle Fenster raus. Also, dass du überhaupt auf die Idee kommst, dass das eine Variable ist. Für mich ist das Fenster einfach Haus, Teil des Hauses. Und ich kann gucken, was kann man da ranhängen oder so von mir aus, aber das Fenster selbst ist fucking konstant. Und da zu sagen, alle Fenster raus, für mich allein die Frage, was ist dann für die Mittelwelt, haben wir dann einen Tag, ist dann ein Loch in der Wand oder so? Das ist auch meine grösste Angst, ist ein Fenster kaputt zu machen, wenn ich dann mit meinem, ich habe jetzt einen Plastikball und ich habe einen Holzstock und mit dem Holzstock haue ich den Plastikball. Und man denkt sich ja, wie hart muss ich den hauen, um da durch die Scheibe zu kommen. Das finde ich spannender, darüber zu reden. Naja, weil das Ding ist ja, ich habe mich ja mit 9-11 ein bisschen beschäftigt. So, und da gibt es ja die 9-11-Verschwörungstheorien. Dass zu viele Leute, dass nur eingestürzt ist, weil zu viele Leute mit einem Plastikball... Und da kommt oft das Argument von Verschwörungstheoretiker, das Flugzeug ist nicht hart genug, um überhaupt in den Turm reinzufliegen. Das würde einfach am Turm kaputt gehen, aber nicht eindringen. Weil die stellen sich dann vor, Tischtennisball, selbst wenn du den ganz hart gegen den Tischtennisschläger wirfst, macht der den nie kaputt, weil der ist einfach nicht genug. Wissen die das nicht aus einem Tischtennisballmaterial?
Ja, aber die sagen, das ist halt nur so Aluminium, Aluminium ist nicht so stark und so und das ist alles nur leicht verkleidet.
Und dem liegt ja ein grundlegend falsches Verständnis von Energie zugrunde, weil Energie ist ja Masse mal Geschwindigkeit Quadrat.
Das heißt, wenn etwas schneller wird, hat es mehr Energie.
Zum Quadrat.
Das heißt, wenn es doppelt so schnell ist, hat es viermal so viel Energie. Und was das ist, ist relativ egal. Und es gibt auch Videos, wo ein Tischtennisball auf den Tischtennisleger geschossen wird und der geht da durch. Ja. Wenn der schnell, das ist scheiss egal, was es ist, weil wenn der schnell ist, hat der genug Energie. Und deswegen denke ich immer, Moment, wenn ich jetzt meinen Plastikball gegen das Fenster trete, ich denke, es ist ein Plastikball, Plastik ist schwächer als Glas. Aber ja, ich denke mir, das ergibt schon Sinn. Obwohl ich die Formel kenne, kriege ich meine Intuition nicht eingehämmert. Das ist mal immer so. Weil ich denke, das ist doch scheißegal, ich kann den so fest, wie ich will, gegen das Fenster deppern. Das ist ja so ein windiger Plastikball. Aber es stimmt nicht, das Fenster kann irgendwann kaputt gehen, wenn es zu hart ist, das ist das Problem, man kann es sich nicht vorstellen, Menschen sind Intuitionswesen, das ist ja auch gut, man folgt der Intuition, aber wenn die falsch ist, es gibt ja so Beispiele, das habe ich mal auch, ob ich das noch zusammenbekommen will, spannend, unterbrech mich bitte, bitte, ich bin heif, dass ich die Formel gerade richtig hinbekommen habe, deswegen jetzt erstmal viel Spaß bei dir. Nee, es gibt dieses Rätsel aus dem Podcast, die neunzwanziger habe ich das gehört, das fand ich ein super spannendes Beispiel für, das ist da auch zitiert worden, weil untersucht wurde, warum wählen Menschen dumm, zum Beispiel gegen ihren eigenen Willen eigentlich oder gegen ihre eigenen Bedürfnisse oder warum.
Und dann gab es so ein sehr gut untersuchtes Rechenexempel, nämlich Golfschläger und Golfball kosten zusammen, jetzt mal als Beispiel, ein Euro zehn.
Was kostet der Golfball und der Golfschläger? Und die meisten beantworten das erstmal falsch. Moment, Moment, wichtig ist, der Golfschläger ist ein Euro teurer als der Ball. Der Golfschläger ist ein Euro teurer als der Ball. Beides kostet zum 1,10. Was kosten Golfschläger und Ball? Und dann sagen die meisten ein Euro und zehn Cent. Der Unterschied wäre aber 90 Cent und nicht der Euro, der gefordert ist. Das beantworten erst einmal intuitiv alle falsch, was auch völlig okay ist. Also da kommt man dann einmal nachdenken, kommt man dann drauf und so, dass es 5 Cent und 1,05 Euro ist und wenn man dann die Gleichung sich überlegt, kommt man schon drauf. Aber das ist gar nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist, dass selbst wenn man das Leuten erklärt, 80 Prozent danach erst mal sagen, nee, ist Quatsch.
Ja, ja, das ist das Beste, ja. Ich glaube, so eine sehr grosse Anzahl Menschen sagt danach immer noch, nee, also glauben dem Naturgesetz Mathematik dann nicht. Und das fand ich so krass, wo man denkt, ja, okay, Menschen sind einfach, also der Urteil war dann, Menschen sind einfach sehr intuitiv. Und Intuition kann ja auch sehr hilfreich sein. Ja, dieser gesunde Menschenverstand ist das Schlimmste, was es gibt. Wenn jemand sagt, ja, gesunder Menschenverstand, dann ist es einfach Quatsch, weil das ist dann einfach Intuition.
Ungesunder Menschenverstand.
Deswegen, das ist da absolut gängig. Aber ich kenne das ja auch, dass ich manche Fakten einfach nicht in meinen Kopf reinkriege und mir einfach denke so, ja, ich weiss schon, dass es so ist, aber irgendwie, es ist ja nur ein Plastikball. Also der ist ja, ich meine, ich sehe ja, wie der fliegt und ich meine, ich haue jetzt auch nicht so fest auf den drauf, Stefan, mach dir bitte keine Sorgen. Weil ich habe Angst, dass die Glasscheibe kaputt geht. Und einen Job suchen oder so, hast du mal überlegt oder so, weil. Nee, nee, nee. Und weil die, meine Angst ist ja, die Glasscheibe geht kaputt und ich kenne mich gut genug, dass ich da einfach nichts machen würde. Also ich würde dann halt damit klarkommen, ein Loch im Haus zu haben. Ich würde dann halt mal gucken, wie ist es mit der Temperatur nachts oder so. Würdest du mal gucken, dass man da mal schaut? Ich würde mal schauen, also ich muss mal gucken, ob ich mal schaue oder mal gucke oder wie man es macht, weil eine Glasscheibe ist ja auch oft zwei Glasscheiben. Und ich glaube, wenn dann eine kaputt geht, würde ich mir denken, ach. Wird gerade aber subventioniert, wenn du dreifach Vergasung machst, kriegst du ordentlich was von Vater Staat. Aber da ist ja Luft dazwischen, oder? Oder ist da so Wacko? Kann ich dir beim besten Willen, den ich nicht habe. Ich habe nicht mal den besten Willen gerade. Aber du willst mir was Falsches sagen? Mit bestem Willen könnte ich dir das nicht beantworten. Ich könnte dir das, selbst wenn ich den besten Willen hätte, würde ich es dir nicht sagen. Ja, aber ich habe ihn nicht.
Ich bin sogar eher bereit, dir was Falsches zu sagen, als das Richtige.
Ja, weil kein Wille ist überwiesen.
Aber warum hast du einen bösen Willen mir gegenüber?
Nö, ich finde einfach diese Frage, ob da jetzt Luft zwischen zwei Fensterscheiben, mea culpa, finde ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig interessant.
Ubi et albi, ähm, wo die ...
Ja, aber ich frage mich halt, wo kommt die Luft her, wo ist das, was ist das für die Luft? So glaube ich, dass du dich das freust. Naja, aber ganz kurz nochmal zu dem Baumarkt, weil dann war vor mir, also, und es wurde immer absurder, bis irgendwann so, ja, und dann hab ich, ähm, ich brauch Schmirgelpapier für so eine Edelstahlplatte, die ich ab und man denkt sich, was sind eure fucking Projekte zu Hause? Macht was Vernünftiges, legt alles hin und geht. Und man sah dem Typen an, dass er so komplett abgestumpft schon ist. Und deswegen würde ich gerne Florentins Serviceecke um die Klammer ergänzen, ganz bitte, ich mache dir keine Sorgen, ganz kleine Klammer und Stephans eine Nachfrage.
Baumarktmitarbeiter, ja.
Das ist halt ein relativ langer Rubriktitel da, ne, weil wir müssen Jingle machen, wir müssen das alles einsprechen.
Ja, ich hänge gut.
Ich glaube, Florentine-Service-Ecke hat auch so einen, finde ich, so einen Klang, der irgendwie, wo man gut reinkommt, schnell ins Thema kommt.
Gut, okay, ich würde mir nur einmal gerne wünschen, dass wir einen Baumarkt-Mitarbeiter fragen, was sind
die krassesten Projekte,
was passiert da in den Häusern Deutschlands,
weil das hat mich wirklich irritiert.
Und wo ist es offensichtlich eine Sexhöhle?
Man einfach sagt, wir haben hier eine Schaukel,
wir haben hier eine Stange.
Ich will so ein Haken
in die Wand schrauben, was
brauche ich da? Da brauchen Sie einen Neuner.
Genau. Also wie schwer hängt denn, wie schwer ist Ihre Fraude? Also … Ah, und wie schwer sind Sie, also sind die beide dann drauf oder was? Und dann ist Jürgen auch dabei oder was? Ja. Jürgen auch dabei, Jürgen, 120. Ja. So, da sind wir ungefähr bei 200 oder so, da brauchen Sie einen Elfer. Ja, und dann brauchen Sie einen Elferhagen Sie auch. Ja gut, weil die ist ja auch mittlerweile, haben wir auch schon am Würstchenwagen bedient.
Ja.
Da ist das so ein klassischer Baumarkt.
Ja, das ist absolut abgestimmt, hat alles gesehen.
Und dann, weil ein Grund, warum ich dann auch im Baumarkt war und selber was machen wollte, war, weil ich eine Woche vorher hatte ich, war ein Handwerker bei mir, die waren da, ich hatte so Heizungspech und so und war, die Dinge waren undicht und so, lief so raus. Oh nein. Und dann waren so, waren den ganzen Tag bei mir Handwerker in der Wohnung. Und wir mit unserem ausgedachten Job, ne, natürlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel, ich hatte jetzt keine Pläne an dem Tag. Ja. Und dann waren halt den ganzen Tag diese Handwerker halt dann da. Und dann war so … hab ich mich so beobachtet, wie die dann so alle am Schuften waren und viel zu tun hatten und war … alles lief so ineinander über und so. Und ich hatte jetzt nicht so ein ,, was zu tun". Und hab nur so gemerkt, wie ich so irgendwie in eine App eingeloggt hab. Und dann konnte ich mich nicht einloggen, weil Zweitfaktor Authentifizierung. Und dann kam bei meinem Mail, kam dann der Code. Und ich habe dann so richtig so, so den Code dann so eingegeben, die vier Stellen. So hin und her geguckt zwischen zwei Bildschirmen. Genau. Und ich habe mich so dabei, er mich bei dem Gedanken, ah, du arbeitest heute aber ganz schön was weg. Ja, du hast heute dein Passwort vergessen. Das ist echt, das ist wirklich ein halber Arbeitstag. Vier, so, G, warte mal, kleines G, ne, grosse, wahrscheinlich alles gross. Es sind vier, es sind aber auch nur vier Ziffern. H, manchmal sind es mehr. Ich überprüfe nochmal. Manchmal sind es mehr. Immer gegenlesen, wichtig, gegenlesen. Nochmal alles gegenlesen, nicht falsch. Im Hintergrund wirklich die grossen Gerähtkraften und so. Schweiss wird weggewischt von der Stirn, so ein Brenner. Mail ist aber richtig. Nochmal, nochmal drücken. Udo, ich kann nicht mehr. Udo, ich brauche eine Pause, Mensch. Ich kann nicht mehr, das ist so schwer, Udo. Bin drin. Udo, das ist so schwer. Bin drin. Schwer. Und drei, zwei, eins. Genau, das ist immer der Grund. Und ich habe mich erfolgreich bei Blue Sky angemeldet. Um da was zu machen, weiß ich nicht mehr. Nichts, um zu scrollen. Ja. Am Ende scrollt man. Aber da hätte ich auch Interesse für Florentins Serviceecke mal die Handwerkerfraktion, weil die haben ja oft wahrscheinlich so, die sind in privaten Räumen und dann so, soll man die Toilette anbieten, soll man ein Glas Wasser anbieten, ist es übergriffig, soll man ein Bierchen kalt stellen, was wollen die, was ist wieder zu viel Klischee, irgendwie so schön dann irgendwie ein Playboy bereitlegen oder wo, also was will man als Handwerker? Würde ich auch bitte gerne in der Florentins Serviceecke mit reinholen. Dann auch unangenehm. Wie soll man sich verhalten?
Ja, und auch Trinkgeld, es ist mir auch nicht klar. Also ich habe es schon ein paar Mal gehört, im Zweifel natürlich immer ringen, klar, ich weiß, ich habe es ein paar Mal anders gesagt, weil es mir anders zugetragen wurde, das ist, noch mal sorry. Lass aber auf, Stefan wird oft hart in die Kritik genommen, aber er hat auch einfach nicht die besten Quellen. Was am Ende meine Schuld ist, gehe ich ein. Ja, aber kritisiert doch direkt die Quellen. Gebt doch bei Stefan, seid doch so wissenschaftlich korrekt und merkt, der Mann tut das Beste mit den grottenschlechten Quellen, die er hat. Geht direkt an die Quelle ran. Ich kann nicht mit unzulänglichem Werkzeug arbeiten. Nee, das geht nicht. Genau, und dann war das Problem, nämlich Handwerker in der Wohnung und ich wollte Trinkgeld geben, habe kein Bargeld, habe ich nicht. Und dann habe ich noch Münzgeld gehabt, aber dann so, ja, und dann gibt man ja wahrscheinlich so zehn Euro jedem oder so. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und dann gibt man so sehr viele Münzen, Jesus. Aber ist das nicht die Kackgeste?
Münzen, also ich finde ja die, also für so eine Lieferung, Essenslieferung ist die grösste Münze, egal in welchem Land ihr lebt, die grösste Münze ist ein guter Orientierungswert, auch wenn wer verreist. In Peru schlagen gerade die Hände über den Kopf zusammen. In Peru, die Tausend-Pesos-Münze, der Goldtaler, das ist doch zu viel! Und letztens hatte ich aber das Problem, dass ich keine Münzen mehr hatte und dann wollte ich kein, nicht kein Trinkgeld geben und ich hatte nur noch einen 10-Euro-Schein. Und dann hat der Bote einfach random das Fünffache vom normalen Trinkgeld bekommen und so, oh cool, danke. Und danach musste ich aber wieder zurückgehen zu zwei und ich weiß nicht, was, welche Botschaften ich damit sende, ob das so ein, war der Service besonders gut? H ich irgendwas genau richtig gemacht oder so, hetzt der jetzt wieder dieser Performance hinterher oder so, ich weiss es nicht, aber es war einfach, ich gebe lieber zu viel als gar nichts, das wäre richtig unangenehm. Weil dann denkt man so, ich höre nämlich auch von Leuten, was ich niemals machen würde, der Service war so schlecht, dann habe ich ganz wenig Trinkgeld gegeben.
Und das würde ich erstens nie machen und zweitens habe ich immer Angst, dann zu wenig Trinkgeld zu geben, weil ich nicht die falsche Botschaft senden will.
Weil wenn ich dann kein Trinkgeld gebe, denkt die Person, war ich nicht freundlich genug, habe ich nicht.
Vielleicht ist der Service schlecht, weil davor die ganze Zeit Leute zu wenig Trinkgeld gegeben haben.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Also vielleicht ist es auch ein Henne-Ei-Ding.
Ja, aber diese ganze Trinkgeldfrage ist wirklich immer noch sehr interessant.
Ja, kann auch sein. Also vielleicht ist es auch ein Henne-Ey-Ding. Ja, aber diese ganze Trinkersprache ist wirklich sehr, sehr, immer noch sehr interessant. Ja, und dann, wie gesagt, dieser Moment, wo man dann so einen Haufen Münzen gibt, immer ein bisschen weird, weil es so ... Ja, das ist so Klimperzeug. Klimperzeug. Vor allem, also du wirfst es ja dann auf den Boden irgendwie, dann rollen die, dann rollen die rum die Münzen, dann müssen die da hinterher hecheln und dann die Treppe runterrollen, dann manche Münzen die Treppe. Das ist dann unangenehm. Das ist dann mein kleines Spiel, das sieht, dass die das so hinwerft. Ja, ich finde es auch süß, aber das irgendwie ist dann auch unangenehm so. Aber es gibt auch eine schöne Last Week Tonight Folge von John Oliver, weil jetzt irgendwie Trump die Steuer. Anders als das Last Week Tonight mit John Oliver. Nee, wie heißt er? Ja. Der Koch. Ach so, Jamie Oliver. Jamie Oliver, ja. Das wäre zum Beispiel ein Gag gewesen. Super. So, ähm. Baut euch selber zusammen. Und da hat irgendwie, wurden jetzt die Steuern auf Trinkgeld irgendwie erlassen oder irgendwie sowas. Und jetzt fangen ganz viele Branchen an. Irgendwie sowas. Du hast halt 30 Jungen übergeguckt, aber. Ja ... Jetzt fangen ganz viele Branchen an, auch Trinkgeld zu nehmen. Also da wurde irgendjemand das Auto abgeschleppt und dann musst du zum Autohof hin, um das Auto wiederzuholen und dann konntest du angeben, wie viel Trinkgeld willst du geben. Und da hat die auch gesagt, ja fickt euch, auf gar keinen Fall. Oder irgendwo in so einer Mall konntest du dir so Soft-Eis holen bei so einem Roboter. Da drückst du drauf und dann macht ein Roboter dir Soft-Eis. Und da auch, wie viel Trinkgeld möchten sie geben? Dem Roboter?
der Industrie, den Roboterbauer oder der Laden das Trinken.
Und das fand ich super, weil ich glaube, das ist
bei manchen, es gibt ja zwei Arten
der Revolution. Es gibt einmal
das Gegenarbeiten und dann
gibt es ja den Akzelerationismus, dass du
sagst, du gehst so hart rein
in die herrschende Ideologie, dass du die Absurdität quasi offenlegst. Und ich glaube, das müssen wir bei Trinkgeld machen. Wir müssen alle so hart verwirren und Trinkgeld geben in Situationen, wo es gar keinen Sinn ergibt und dann das wieder erwarten, bis irgendwann das komplette System implodiert. Genau, wir geben dem Arzt Trinkgeld, wir geben dem Schaffner Trinkgeld. Das System ist Fakt. Das System ist komplett Fakt. Wir gehen nach der Zugfahrt, gehen wir vorne zum ICE-Schaffner und drücken dem zwei Euro-Stücke in die Hand. So, ich will die Welt brennen sehen, ich will Chaos. Ich hab schon so oft von Leuten, die das zurückbekommen, so, nee, will ich nicht. Und das ist so unangenehm, weil dann kommt man sich so gönnerhaft vor. Und ich weiß schon, dass uns Leute dann gerne, wenn wir so Trinkgeldthema haben, so Klassismus oder so vorwerfen, weil wir uns darüber lustig machen, weil das Leute davon angewiesen sind. Nee, das stimmt überhaupt. Ich weiss, doch, ich habe da so eine Nachricht bekommen, aber das ist ja nicht der Fall, das ist auch nie unsere Intention. Wir wollen einfach nur sagen, an den Pranger stellen, das System ist Fakt. Man weiss nicht wann, wie viel, wo und das ist echt ein bisschen bescheuert. Wie kommen wir denn darüber, dass das der Punkt ist? Ich glaube, weil wir Gags machen über das Thema Trinkgeld. Ja, weil es ein sozial unangenehmes Thema ist einfach. Wobei Trinkgeld auch ein scheiss System ist. Ich glaube, dass die den Nachrichtensender das als Affront gegen eine Arbeiterklasse, die auf Trinkgeld angewiesen hat, irgendwie aufgefasst hat. Ich verstehe diesen Bogen auch nicht unbedingt. Ich glaube, es ist das klassische Thema des Jokes, mit Stil des Jokes verwechselte Ding. Aber ja, das ist nicht das Ziel. Es ist nur wirklich die, das System ist wirklich ein bisschen weird. Und ich finde das, also ich glaube, wenn man jetzt davon redet, Klassismus und die werden ausgebeutet oder was auch immer, ich glaube, die haben doch am wenigsten Bock auf Trinkgeld. Also ich glaube, die Leute, die auf Trinkgeld angewiesen sind, leiden doch am meisten unter diesem System. Die wären doch am frohsten, wenn es ersetzt werden würde durch ein anderes System. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Leute jetzt unbedingt Trinkgeld haben wollen, also das System Trinkgeld haben wollen. Die, glaube ich, leiden ja am meisten darunter. Und es war auch in diesem John Oliver Bericht von Leuten, die meinen, die sind komplett darauf angewiesen und wenn es irgendwie schlecht läuft, dann können sie ihre Miete nicht zahlen und so. Die sind da total prekär unterwegs. Die haben, glaube ich, am wenigsten Bock drauf. Das heisst, ich glaube, die würden am meisten profitieren, wenn das System implodiert. Also ich rufe auf zur grossen Implosion. Jeder gibt überall Trinkgeld. Jeder, dem Postboten, dem Arzt, dem Zugführer, in jeder Situation überall Trinkgeld. Stefan, ich finde, du hast heute echt, ich finde, du hast echt eine gute Arbeit geworfen. Was, warum, nee, hä? Nee, ich finde, das war ein guter Podcast. Wir haben eine Firma zusammen, das ist letztendlich, was wir gemeinsam tun. Schärfer. Das war ein guter Podcast. Ernsthaft, ich finde, das war ein guter Podcast hier. Das ist für dich. So, und so, gebt euren Kollegen Trinkgeld, jeder gibt jedem Trinkgeld, gebt euren Eltern Trinkgeld. Sagt Mama, das war ein echt gutes Essen, danke, zack, 20 Euro auf dem Tisch und dann geht man und irgendwann drehen alle durch und es gibt eine grosse Revolution und es gibt die Anti-Trinkgeld-Partei und wirklich, es tut sich mal was. Es ist eine Kunstprojekt, eine Art Kunstprojekt. Wir bringen das Ganze durch so ein weirdes, alle Schippen rein, lassen wir es implodieren. Ich finde es super, ich finde es eine richtig tolle Idee. Genauso möchte ich aber auch, dass alle Trinkgeld ablehnen, dass jetzt plötzlich alle anfangen, Trinkgeld abzulehnen und man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo es ist und wohin, wohin zu viel. Das darf erst mal das Ziel sein. Oder man sagt, ich will mehr. Nee, weil das Ding ist, wenn jetzt alle auch noch ablehnen müssen, dann geben ja alle nur mit dem Wissen, ich krieg's eh wieder zurück. Ach so, nee, dann macht das lieber so, alle, die Trinkgeld kriegen, verlangen mehr Trinkgeld. Die sagen, das ist zu wenig Trinkgeld, ich will mehr. Und dann ist einfach nur noch Chaos und Strude. Ganz ehrlich, diese Chaos-Strude. Diese Chaos-Offenheit wäre super. Ja, mega. Manchmal kriegt man dann so einen Blick und man denkt sich, was so wenig, ich weiß nicht, was hier üblich ist. Ja, und online und in persona, überall trinken, überall trinken. Genau, bei Frisören war es nämlich auch mal ein Thema, weil ich war in so einem Barbershop, wo man online vorher bezahlt, den Termin, beim Buchen des Termins zahlt man, geht dann dahin und da gibt niemand Trinker. Ist mir noch nie aufgefallen und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das da üblich ist. Das habe ich mir mal erzählt, dass ich meinem Friseur nicht Trinkgeld gebe. Da haben viele gesagt, doch, mach das, dass es einen Job, der auf angewiesen ist, auf Trinkgeld. Und da habe ich aber nicht so meine Erfahrungen nach, aber kann schon sein. Ich war auch schon bei Friseuren, in so einem klassischen Friseursalon, wo man Trinkgeld gibt. I know, das macht man dann. Aber bei diesem Online-Tool und dann ist es auch so ein Barber, wo nur Leute mit so Rasierern sitzen und dann bis nach Viertelstunde ein bisschen raus. Und es ist eh so boom, boom, boom und da machen alle online, da gibt es auch keine Kasse, die haben auch kein Chipgerät mehr bei sich. Muss ich mir dann vorher Geld abheben? I guess. Das Problem ist, wenn du Friseure fragst, soll man Trinkgeld geben, sagen die natürlich nicht, nein, auf keinen Fall. So, gerade diese Mittelberufe, die, also die, klar kann auch nicht jeder Friseur für den Berufsstand Friseur sprechen, so, das ist ja natürlich auch so, manchmal schon, manchmal nicht, keine Ahnung, hab nichts dagegen, so, das ist natürlich schwierig. Macht an die Tür, an der Tür sind da manchmal so Sticker, wie es ist so ein Laden, wo man als Kind reinfliegen kann. Genau, so wurde schon eingebrochen, sowas. Die klassischen Sticker. Da soll so ein Sticker sein, Trinkgeld, Fragezeichen, angekreuzt, ja oder nein, angekreuzt mit dem Edding, und wenn ja, wie viel, da muss man da eine Prozentzahl eingeben. Und dann weisst du, wenn du den Laden betrittst, kannst du mit arbeiten, kannst du mit rechnen, keine Fragen offen. Wir sind ein Laden, wie bei uns ist es üblich, zehn Prozent Trinkgeld zu geben, brauchen wir. Das ist an der Tür vorne. Ich, langfristig, ich erhoffe mir, dass wir mit der nächsten Legislaturperiode, 2028 oder irgendwo so wirklich an einen Punkt kommen, wo einfach sagen, Trinkgeld wird komplett gestrichen, Preise hoch, es gibt Länder, wo das funktioniert, wir brauchen hier eine neue Revolution. Okay, bis dahin gibt jedem, auch euren Eltern, auch Ärzten, wirklich jedem gibt ihr jetzt Trinkgeld. Ärzten, Kollegen, Freunden, wenn jemand einen guten Vorschlag macht, hey, lass uns doch Pizza bestellen,
ey, guter Vorschlag, zack, zwei Euro.
Einfach wirklich alles,
lass das Geld fliessen. Und umgekehrt auch, wenn
ihr irgendwie einer älteren Frau oder so
helft, kurz was, irgendwie ein Paket
kurz bei ihr rein, Tür aufhalten oder sowas,
dann auch die Hand auf den Halt. Ja, absolut,
ja, in die Richtung musst du auch gehen,
ja. Also ruhig kurz mal
warten und, kommt was? Ach so, nichts. Okay. Gerne aufrunden, auch an der Kasse. Ja, kostet 17,20 Euro. 20 Euro. Können wir nicht annehmen, wir haben keine Rechnung. Einfach 20. Und will ich auch einfach direkt werfen. Einfach nicht werfen. Wir müssen die... Ich freue mich sehr über die Nachricht. Schickt uns an unsere Mailadresse. Handwerker, Friseure, Trinkgeld, Leute. Kontaktformular bei daspodcast.com oder podcast.fail. Da geht ihr auf unsere Website. So, und dann schreibt uns die Geschichten. Wem habt ihr Trinkgeld gegeben, wo es normalerweise nicht üblich ist? Wir wollen die Stories, wir wollen die Reaktionen. Habt ihr euren Eltern Trinkgeld gegeben? Habt ihr euren Kindern Trinkgeld gegeben? Den Lehrern? Oder die Lehrer den Schülern? Random, was ist passiert? Jemand hat euch den Weg erklärt. Was ist mit Drogendealern? Dankeschön. Zehner. Was mit Drogendealern gibt man denen Trinkgeld? Ich habe noch nie Drogen gekauft in meinem Leben. Ich schon, habe noch nicht Trinkgeld gegeben. Warum denn da nicht? Weil, also sind die so cool und so ausserhalb des Systems, dass man denen keinen Trinkgeld ... Wäre das eine Faux-Pas? Also das wäre so ein Larry-David-Moment. Ich kaufe das erste Mal in meinem Leben Drogen und sage dann, stimmt so. Und dann wäre ich ja Chancen einfach. Oder was passiert da? Seid ihr Drogen, dann meldet euch. So, jetzt Rosen runter, ich habe keinen Trinker gegeben. Und dann sagt er jetzt, fick dich Stefan,
wir sind auf Trinkgeld angewiesen.
Ja, verdammt nochmal. Ja, wir sind auch
auf Leute, die Drogen kaufen, angewiesen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Meldet euch, ihr habt da mehr Erfahrung als wir,
ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dahin,
viel Spaß, haut rein, alles Gute,
alles Gute, neun,, macht's Rutsch.